[Music]
today we'll start from zero and finish
the video with our own custom machine
learning model deployed to the cloud as
an API we will pull some actual user
data that we have saved in the firestore
database then we'll export it to data
lab so we can train a Python based
machine learning model with virtually
unlimited compute resources once we have
a solid model in place we'll deploy it
to ml engine so we can version it and
analyze it in production and finally we
will expose it to the universe by making
it available in a firebase cloud
function but before you that make sure
to LIKE and subscribe and I'll be giving
away this one-of-a-kind Python brain
t-shirt all you have to do is leave a
comment below then we'll pick a random
winner via livestream next week this
video was made in collaboration with
Roddy Chilika who is get this only in
the seventh grade and already doing
crazy stuff with tensorflow firebase and
a bunch of other tech in addition to
this video you'll also want to check out
his github repo that shows you how to
train a tensor flow model directly in a
cloud function now we're ready to get
started and we'll do something that
we've never done on this channel before
and that's right Python code Python is
the most commonly used language for
machine learning problems and it's
pretty easy to learn if you already know
JavaScript if you want to get inspired
by Python head over to Kaggle and check
out some of the amazing work done by a
real data scientist in today's video
you'll learn not only how to build and
train a machine learning model but also
how to deploy it to the cloud as a real
product that people can use the first
step in any machine learning problem is
the underlying data a practical use case
for a firebase developer would be to
save some information about a user in
the firestore database then train that
data to build a predictive model that
adds some value to the user experience
if we look in our database you can see
here we have a collection of developer
records and each one will tell us what
tools this developer uses and their
overall happiness as a developer this is
just synthetic data that I generated for
this demo but you can think of it as
being information that you might collect
from a user survey or something along
those lines machine learning problems
generally require a huge amount of data
and also a huge amount of compute
resources to run operations on that data
we're going to use a service on GCP
called data lab it allows us to stream
and process our data in the cloud which
means you can
spin up a GPU powered supercomputer from
your laptop and then just shut it off
when you're done to get going with data
lab you'll need to have a firebase or
GCP project and then we have a couple of
things to run here from the command-line
basically you're just installing data
lab and then calling data lab create
with the name that you want to give it
what this does is give you an
interactive Python or Jupiter notebook
in the cloud that you can use to run
Python code and you can allocate as much
CPU or memory that you need and also
attach GPUs to it the nice thing about
this notebook is that it's tightly
integrated with all of your other GCP
resources such as storage buckets
bigquery and everything else
it should give you a link to localhost
that will show a notebook that looks
like this the first thing I'm going to
do is install firebase admin by running
exclamation pip install firebase admin
now if you're not familiar with Jupiter
notebooks they're basically just a nice
UI for executing Python code we can put
each code block in its own cell and then
execute those one by one by clicking the
play button you'll notice that there are
a ton of examples in the data lab
environment so definitely check those
out especially if you're not super
comfortable with Python then notebook
we're building today does four main
things first it brings in our data from
fire store then we do an exploratory
data analysis then we split the data up
and train an algorithm and then finally
export it to a cloud storage bucket
first we'll need access to fire store so
we'll go into the firebase project
settings and generate a new private key
that will give you a JSON file that you
can save in the root of the data lab
there are two dependencies that you'll
see commonly in machine learning
problems one is pandas which allows us
to put data in a data frame and the
second one is numpy which helps us make
scientific calculations on arrays what
we'll be doing in just a second here is
taking our fire stored data and putting
it into a panda's data frame and numpy
will help us generate some random
synthetic data that we can use for this
demo from there we have a library called
pi plot that will help us generate some
charts then we'll import firebase admin
and initialize it with our credentials
the process is basically identical to
node J s or any other language for that
matter this next part shows how I
generated the synthetic data and I'm not
going to go through it line by line but
just explain what's going on at a
highway
almost all machine learning problems
boil down to finding a signal that's
hidden within some noise so the data
I've generated below is slightly random
but also has some structure to it as
well the value that we're trying to
predict is developer happiness
so I started by giving every user a
random happiness between negative 25 and
25 then I have a dictionary with 6
different programming languages in it
each one that will give the developer a
different level of happiness and I also
gave each developer a value of firebase
which when true makes the developer much
happier than when false but the general
idea here is that the data is partially
random and partially fixed our goal is
to create an algorithm that can detect
which features are important and which
aren't
in this example firebase should be the
most important followed by programming
language and an age shouldn't be
important at all if you have your own
data in fire store you can just skip
this step and then in the next cell I
will actually retrieve that data from
the database and then save it to a CSV
file so we don't have to reread it each
time and get charged for additional
reads in fire store conveniently pandas
has a to CSV method that we can use to
just quickly save our data to a CSV file
so now if we come back to our notebook
we can just run pandas read CSV and then
the first thing I'll do is just sample
10 items from that data frame to see
what the data looks like machine
learning is not magic and the first
thing you should do once you have your
data is run an exploratory analysis the
idea is to uncover some signals here
that you can use to nudge your algorithm
in the right direction and the reason we
put our data in a panda's data frame is
because it gives us a pull bunch of
methods to help analyze and also clean
the data before it goes into an
algorithm so here we're running data
frame sample to just get ten random rows
out of the data set and a data frame is
treated very much like an array you can
see here that I'm doing data frame with
the happiness key on there and then I'm
gonna run plot histogram to give us a
visual idea of what the actual label
looks like so you can see here we have a
pretty normal distribution of happiness
values and this is what we want our
algorithm to be able to predict based on
the other features in the data another
thing you can do is run data frame
describe to get common statistics on the
data set such
the mean standard deviation and things
like that so now that we've explored our
data it's time to introduce a new
library called scikit-learn you've
probably heard a lot of hype surrounding
tensorflow and deep neural networks and
those tools are great but they're often
overkill for a lot of problems
scikit-learn contains a huge collection
of tools for tackling machine learning
problems the first thing we'll do is use
it to clean our data to make sure that
all the values are numeric which is
required for most machine learning
algorithms currently you'll notice that
our programming language value is a
string value so what we need to do is
get all of the unique elements in that
array and convert them to a number then
assign each value to the corresponding
number we can do this easily with
scikit-learn by creating a label encoder
and then having it fit transform that
column to the numeric classes if we
sample the data frame again you'll see
that our language column is now numeric
and no longer a string the next thing
scikit-learn will help us with is
slicing the data into different chunks
that we can use to train an algorithm
we'll define a new variable named X
which is all of our features and the
data - the one we're trying to predict
which is happiness then we'll define y
as the variable that we are trying to
predict now we need to separate these
into sets for training and then another
one for testing or validation so I'm
using this train test split method
passing it our X Y values and in making
the test size be one third of the total
data set size which means we'll be
training on 66% of the data the reason
you don't train all the data is because
then you have no way to validate whether
or not the model is any good and you
want a model that can kind of generalize
the overall data set so now we're going
to train an algorithm that's usually
very good out of the box which is a
random forest in our case we have a
value between negative 100 and positive
100 and the predicted value can be
anything in between there so we have an
infinite number of possible predictions
which means we're dealing with a
regression problem this differs from a
classification problem where you might
be predicting different labels like
whether or not a picture is a dog or a
cat the code in this last cell is very
simple we just have the random forest
regressor which we fit to our X&Y data
and then we predict on the features in
the test set of that
there are a bunch of different options
you can pass to the regressor to try to
fine-tune it
that's called hyper parameter tuning and
then you need to have a metric to
analyze its performance in this case
we're going to use mean absolute error
which means that our random forest model
is about 18 points wrong on average so
how good is that exactly well the best
place to start is just by comparing it
to a random set of predictions in the
next cell we can see that completely
random predictions produce a mean
absolute error of about 56 which means
that our algorithm is relatively
effective now the last thing we want to
do is figure out which features and the
data were most important in the
decision-making process as you can see
here the age was not important at all
because it was completely random and
then firebase and programming languages
were the most important so at this point
we have a predictive model but we have
no way for anybody to use it if you're
building a product you most likely want
to serve that up as an API so it can be
consumed by some kind of front-end
application like angular or iOS or
whatever and that's where ml engine
comes in the last cell in the notebook
that you're looking at here is taking
the model that we just trained dumping
it as a job load file and then saving it
in our firebase storage bucket and
they'll engine will be able to read the
model file in the bucket and then serve
out predictions in a highly performant
way with predictions being served over
the network in just a matter of a few
hundred milliseconds so before we head
over to ml engine go into your firebase
storage bucket and make sure that you
have your job load file saved in its own
individual folder from there you'll want
to go back to the GCP console and then
go to enable api's you'll need to enable
the cloud build API because your models
will actually be versioned and of course
we'll need the ml engine API as well
from there you can navigate over to the
cloud ml engine dashboard and the first
thing I want to do is create a model and
give that model a name you'll need this
name later when we get to the cloud
function the great thing about this
system is that your models can have
multiple versions so you can see how
their performance changes over time it's
important that you fill out things
correctly here like our Python version
as 2.7 in the environment and we're
using the scikit-learn framework and the
version is 19 and the runtime version is
1.9
from there you'll need to select the
folder that has this model in it which
is that job would file that we saved
earlier it'll take a few minutes to save
but once that's done you'll be able to
either make predictions from the command
line or from other Google api's such as
a cloud function as we'll see here next
once the model goes into production
we'll be able to get some actual
performance metrics about how it's
handling its workload so now we're on to
the final step and that's writing a
cloud function that can consume this
model for that will switch over to vs
code and first we'll go into the command
line run firebase and net functions then
we'll see the end of the functions
directory and install Google api's the
Google API package for node will allow
us to authenticate the cloud function
and then make requests to the ml API
without the need for an HTTP library I'm
using typescript here but you could just
as easily use vanilla Jas will import
Google from Google API s then reference
ml l version 1 the function itself is
called predict happiness and it's just a
regular HTTP function but you could use
any kind of cloud function here you want
a good alternative would be to run a
prediction every time a new record is
added to the firestore database we're
going to use this single cloud function
to make requests to potentially multiple
models so we'll have the request body
define which model should make the
prediction and then the instances will
be the actual data that we're trying to
predict which is typically an array with
the same shape in which you trained your
actual machine learning model so now
that we have the request body we can
format our request to the Google API
this request requires authentication
which we can get by calling Google auth
get application default and that will
connect our firebase credentials with
the Google API from there we'll set up a
variable for the model name which needs
to have your project ID in it as well as
the name of the actual model that you
gave it in the ml engine console and now
everything is in place to make a
prediction call to the ml engine API we
call projects predict pass in our auth
credentials the name of the model and
then also the instances that we're
trying to predict this can actually be
an array of arrays if we want to make
multiple predictions from a single cloud
function call
and then typescript gets a little
confused right here so we need to add as
any after the argument to predict so
that should resolve with the predictions
from our model and then we can send that
back out as the response from this HTTP
function at this point you could deploy
this cloud function and you essentially
have an API endpoint with your machine
learning model but we're just going to
run it locally and then we'll test it
with an application called insomnia
insomnia is a free desktop app that you
can install and it allows you to make
HTTP calls in this nice user interface
so first in the JSON body will declare
the model name which is developer
happiness for the instances we pass an
array of arrays where each array is
going to be a prediction that we're
trying to make so these values match the
features in our original data set for
example column one would be the users
age column to whether or not these
firebase and column three they're
encoded programming language now if we
send this request to our function we get
a response back in about 400
milliseconds that gives us the
prediction from those instances so each
set of features sent from the request
here on the Left got a different
happiness prediction from the response
here on the right in other words we
started with basically nothing and now
we have an endpoint in the cloud for our
custom machine learning model I'm gonna
go ahead and wrap things up there if
this video helped you please like and
subscribe and you can find the full
source code on angular firebase com
if you're serious about building a
project with firebase or Google cloud
consider upgrading to a pro membership
at angular firebase com you'll get
access to a whole bunch of exclusive
content designed to help you build and
ship your app faster thanks for watching
and I'll talk to you soon
you